nous aimerions tous avoir une mémoire
d'éléphant
nous aimerions tous connaître les dates
d'anniversaire de nos proches ne pas
oublier nos agendas
cette fameuse liste de courses encore
mieux ne plus en avoir besoin
nous nous faisons tous du souci pour ces
oublis du quotidien j'imagine que
certains d'entre vous ont déjà vécu ce
moment où sur un parking on ne se
souvient plus où est-ce qu'on a garé sa
voiture
j'imagine que je ne suis pas la seule à
avoir entendu maman tu as oublié mes
chaussures de foot ou encore de ne plus
être capable de remettre le nom de cette
personne qui me fait signe de l'autre
côté de la rue alors pour nous rassurer
on utilise des tas d'outils numériques
des téléphones des tablettes devrait
prothèse mesic
alors on les emmène de partout on envoie
à l'école en envoie au restaurant et on
en voit aussi dans des salles de tedx et
ces outils on les envie parce que eux
ils sont capables de tout garder en
mémoire
je suis chercheur au laboratoire
d'études des mécanismes cognitifs et
j'aimerais vous réconcilier avec votre
mémoire
j'aimerais vous expliquez que l'oubli
est nécessaire qu'il est naturel alors
la mémoire comment ça marche
pour vous expliquer son fonctionnement
si vous êtes d'accord
j'aimerais vous soumettre à quelques
petits exercices pour commencer on va se
mettre dans des conditions bien
particulières puisque pour faire ses
exercices vous n'aurez pas le droit de
noter quoi que ce soit ni sur un papier
ni sur vos téléphones
on va essayer de faire ça de mémoire
pour commencer j'aimerais que vous
écoutiez attentivement les séries de
chiffres que je vais vous donner et
essayer de les répéter après mois dans
le même ordre et à la même vitesse que
moi est-ce que vous êtes prêts 6 4 3 9
ça marche bien une autre 8 5 7 3 2 8
il a finalement pas mal d'éléphant on
continue 1 2 051 9 7 3
finalement pas tant que ça cette série
elle est nettement plus compliqué la
raison elle est évidente
il y avait beaucoup trop de chiffres
dans cette série fait mémoire que l'on
vient de solliciter s'appelle notre
mémoire à court terme
cette mémoire va nous permettre de
retenir
peu d'informations en moyenne 7 et va
nous permettre de les garder quelques
secondes à plus de 30 secondes après
quoi elles s'effacent et elle s'efface
naturellement il aurait ainsi était plus
simple que je vous dise
à la place de cette dernière série 1 2
051 9 7 3 qu'il s'agissait du 12 mai
ce système il est fait pour nous
empêcher de tout mémoriser
il n'y aurait aucun sens à tout
apprendre
la première série de chiffres que je
vous ai donné celle que vous avez tous
réussi à me rapporter est-ce que vous en
souvenez une personne merci madame
cette série de chiffres il n'y avait
aucun intérêt à la retenir
par contre si je vous avais dit qu'il
s'agissait du code à inscrire ce soir
sur votre feuille d'imposition pour ne
pas payer d'impôts cette année les
choses auraient été nettement différente
vous auriez pris le temps de les
mémoriser
car si nous souhaitons que ces
informations ne s'efface pas en 30
secondes
il faut produire un effort cognitif cet
effort cognitif c'est ce que nous
appelons l'encodage en mémoire à long
terme
qu'est ce que c'est que l'encodage mais
c'est une façon de dépasser les limites
de notre mémoire à court terme pour
faire rentrer les informations dans
notre mémoire
allons
terme cette mémoire à long terme elle
elle est illimitée en durée de stockage
vous avez des souvenirs qui ont dix
vingt trente même 40 ans vous êtes ainsi
tous capables de finir cette liste de
conjonctions mais où est donc même si
vous ne vous souvenez plus qu'il s'agit
des conjonctions de coordination cette
phrase est dans votre mémoire depuis
votre enfance
et cette mémoire à long terme elle est
aussi limité en quantité d'informations
qu'elle peut contenir des sons des
odeurs des images la couleur de votre
première voiture une coupe de cheveux
raté l'endroit où nous nous trouvions le
11 septembre 2001
lorsqu'on nous a annoncé les attentats
de new york
une quantité infinie d'informations plus
ou moins importantes
aucun téléphone aussi intelligent qu'il
soit ne pourrez stocker autant
d'informations alors essayons de faire
travailler notre mémoire à long terme
nous allons profiter de ce magnifique
théâtre et regarder le plafond qui se
trouve au dessus de nous
regardez le attentivement nous allons
essayer d'encoder cette magnifique
fresque peinte tout là haut en nous
demandant ce que font ces personnages et
à quoi il pense c'est un jeu délicieux
quand on se retrouve à la terrasse d'un
café et qu'on regarde les gens dans la
rue et qu'on se dit mais oui vont à quoi
il pense porter notre attention sur eux
c'est ce que nous allons faire avec ces
différents personnages
on va zoom et certains de ses effets
vous pouvez voir apollon qui sort du
soleil sur son char tiré par trois
magnifiques chevaux fou
mettez-vous à sa place à quoi peut-il
penser à ce moment à côté nous voyons
dante tout de rouge vêtu il est assis
ils alertent s'interroger on pourrait
imaginer qu'il est en train de préparer
le voyage du personnage de son oeuvre la
divine comédie
regardez le bien un peu plus haut
nous avons quatre petits anges qui ont
l'air de se chamailler pour un objet
qu'on voit pas très bien on pourrait
imaginer qu'il s'agisse d'une bouteille
d'eau des montagnes d'auvergne et enfin
on a un autre apollon qui est assis
fièrement sur son nuage pendant qu'un
ange est en train de lui apporter une
couronne de lauriers
imaginez-vous ce à quoi il est en train
de penser à ce moment précis le peintre
qui a réalisé cette oeuvre
tout là-haut s'appelle jules tulou
prenez un instant pour essayer de
mémoriser son nom
pour encoder une information il ne
suffit pas de regarder ou d'écouter il
faut porter son attention sur ces choses
là tension
c'est un élément essentiel de notre
mémoire
c'est la base de notre encodage vous
connaissez tous le jeu du bonneteau
c'est un jeu de rue ou un individu vous
promet de l'argent si vous réussissez à
retrouver une pièce qu'il a caché sous
un gobelet vous pensez tout ce qu'il
s'agit d'une arnaque
et ben moi j'aimerais vous montrer que
si vous étiez très attentifs vous
pourriez déjouer ce tour je vous laisse
regarder cette vidéo
soyez bien attentifs à l'endroit où se
trouve la pièce ne lâchait pas cette
pièce des yeux on a ralenti les
mouvements pour que ce soit plus simple
mais ne vous laissez pas distraire
vous aviez tous la pièce parfait vous
avez été très attentifs peut-être même
un peu trop parce qu'on focalisons votre
attention sur ce gobelet vous n'avez pas
vu qu'un autre gobelet avait été
remplacé par un poivron de la même
couleur et que ce poivrons a été déplacé
sur la table pendant plusieurs secondes
à votre insu parce que l'attention c'est
ça lorsque l'on porte notre attention
sur une chose nous ne pouvons pas
l'apporter sur autre chose en même temps
et si nous souhaitons encoder
correctement il faut que toute notre
attention soit disponible alors fort de
tous ces conseils
nous allons essayer maintenant de
mémoriser 12 mo bien plus que votre
mémoire à court terme
portez bien votre attention sur chacun
de ses mots etes-vous prêts et en pluie
estuaire cascades confluent fleuve
torrent ruisseau canal lac
marc et océans
vous les avez tous alors gardez les
précieusement dans votre mémoire
une fois on codé hélas les informations
peuvent encore s'effacer si nous
souhaitons vraiment les maintenir dans
notre mémoire à long terme il faut
qu'elle soit consolidée une manière de
les consolider
ça va être de répéter ce que nous avons
appris révisé en d'autres termes les
encoder à plusieurs reprises et à chaque
répétition d'un autre souvenir va être
renforcée il va être consolidée 6 4 3 9
6 4 3 9 6 capes 3 9
mais il ya quelque chose d'autre qui est
essentiel à la consolidation
c'est le sommeil quand nous dormons
notre cerveau réactive ce que nous avons
appris un peu comme si nous révisions
mais cette fois ci sans aucun effort ce
cerveau endormi va trier les
informations nouvellement encoder il va
ranger celles qui ont de l'importance et
effacer celle qui nous sont inutiles
vous avez tous entendu dire qu'il était
bon de réviser ses leçons le soir avant
d'aller se coucher
eh bien nous avons récemment mis en
évidence que la configuration idéale
était d'intercaler du sommeil entre les
sessions d'apprentissage alors ne
conseiller pas à vos enfants de dormir
en classe mais nous avons pu montrer
qu'effectivement il était bon de réviser
le soir mais que de revoir sa leçon le
matin au lever nous permettait de nous
en souvenir bien plus longtemps donc le
sommeil nous offre un double avantage il
va nous permettre de ré apprendre plus
vite et de retenir plus longtemps
en d'autres termes c'est travailler
moins pour retenir plus alors après
avoir fait un encodage attentif un
stockage consolidé par une bonne nuit de
sommeil
la récupération des informations cette
dernière étape de la mémorisation sera
beaucoup plus facile
est ce que vous vous souvenez des douze
mois que nous avons vu tout à l'heure
alors on va le faire un peu plus
simplement combien d'entre vous se
souviennent du mot fleuve était-il dans
la liste montrez-moi lever les mains
très bien
est ce qu'il y avait le mot montagne non
le mot pluie lever la main key est ce
qu'il y avait le mot lac
oui licorne conifères rivière
vous n'êtes pas tous d'accord
effectivement rivière n'y était pas et
la mémoire
c'est aussi cela la mémoire ce n'est pas
une reproduction parfaite de la réalité
c'est plutôt une reconstruction
un souvenir ce n'est pas une
photographie mais c'est l'interprétation
de cette photographie que nous faisons
en fonction de nos émotions de nos
connaissances est également de notre
motivation
je suis certaine que de cet après midi
chacun d'entre vous en gardera un
souvenir mais ce sera un souvenir
singulier parfaitement différent de
celui de vos voisins
revenons à ce magnifique plafond ne
levait pas les yeux est ce que vous êtes
capable de me dire de quelle couleur
était les chevaux qui tirait le char
d'apollon blanc vous souvenez-vous de
qui a écrit la divine comédie
combien d'ange se battait pour cette
bouteille d'eau des alpes 1 vous avez
parlé de l'auvergne vous vous souvenez
du nom du peintre
j'ai lu tout l'eau je suis persuadé
qu'un a même convenu la série de quatre
chiffres qui ne sert à rien alors au
final la mémoire
qu est ce que c est bien ce sont tous
les moments que l'on a su saisir toutes
les informations sur lesquelles nous
avons pu porter notre attention
celle qui nous ont marqués quand vous
serez la terrasse d'un café les yeux
rivés sur votre téléphone portable
repensez à votre mémoire posez votre
télé fans et regardez autour de vous
demandez vous où vont ces gens à quoi
ils pensent
prenez le temps de faire à temps
sion à ce que vous êtes en train de
vivre pour lui laisser une chance
d'intégrer votre mémoire et après cela
dormez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]